uh hi my name is markiplier
i'm a professional youtuber that
definitely keeps my
youtube base people who are you my
my my loyal my my enablers
my enablers you are my enablers you
enable me
to be who i am and do what i do which is
apparently nothing if you've been
following my channel for the past week
because i've been very busy i leave for
canada tomorrow
yeah i know that was a surprise i knew
about it and it was still a surprise to
me so for the past week i've been doing
everything that i needed to do to get
prepared for my departure to canada
tomorrow because you need a lot of
paperwork
you need like a quarantine plan i'm not
going to pretend like i set all that up
that was done by the production company
that
was running oh god i'm going to canada
because i'm filming something
so i'm going to canada to film the edge
of sleep we're turning it into a tv show
that's pretty cool if you haven't seen
the edge of sleep well you can't see the
edge of sleep because it's a podcast so
if you haven't listened to the edge of
sleep i'll provide a link in the
description below so you can spoil it
before you
watch the tv series that's not a good
sales pitch anyway if you've
if you've if you've seen if you've
listened
if you've listened to the edge of sleep
and you've enjoyed it please leave a
review
a 10 to 20 word review in the comments
below so other people can get a
recommendation for it
either way we're going to film it it's
going to be a bit of a bit of an ordeal
going over there because we got a
quarantine once i get there i got to get
work permits i got to get everything
set up and ready to go i had to prepare
pack get everything
set up and ready for my departure
and one of the things that i was not
able to do is get videos up because
i literally also had to uh
work and prepare and finish writing and
do reviews and and do edits
on the script and the pre-production for
heist 2 which we are filming immediately
after i get back from canada
so uh it's been a little busy but it's
getting better now because once i get
into canada
i will be quarantined for two weeks
which means that i will be in a hotel
doing absolutely nothing for two weeks
which means that you guys get to see my
descent into madness
while i wait in a hotel for the canadian
government to say that i am
good enough to go into their country i
haven't flown on a plane in a while
not i'm scared uh on wednesday there was
an article that talked about this so
some of you may already know about it
and i just want to comment they use this
picture it's not like it's the worst
picture in the world
but i don't know why they keep using it
because if you've been watching my
videos
if you're even watching this right now
and you know my face to even some degree
you can tell that there's something
wrong with my face here you can
you can tell there's nothing wrong with
the photographer don't don't get me
wrong about that it was great
um i had no idea what to do i even asked
like do you smile in the picture are you
supposed to be serious like steve jobs
or something like that
and uh he said i just do whatever feels
comfortable you know just keep it loose
and i did not keep it loose i kept it
stiff
stiff as possible as stiff this is stiff
applier
yeah it ain't right i'm gonna be making
videos while i'm in the hotel i'm going
to be making a lot of videos while i'm
in the hotel
i'm going to be making a lot of videos
of very questionable content while i'm
in the hotel because i'm going to be
really scraping the bottom of the barrel
of content because
like i said i didn't prepare very much
and i have to make
an entire two weeks worth of videos
maybe plus more
because i'll be filming for another few
weeks after that
in a two-week window in one enclosed
room
it's going to get a little weird i think
that's everything i actually have to get
going now because i got to finish
packing
i've got some last minute paperwork to
fill out i've got some last minute
writing to do i got to answer some
emails i got to prepare
i'm going to go do that i'm not even
going to edit this video very well it's
going to be choppy you probably already
know that because you watched it unless
you're one of the weirdos that just
skipped ahead to the end of the video to
see if
there was some kind of conclusion and no
there isn't greg
what are you doing here go back and
watch the beginning of the video get
back to get back there get
get out of here get out of here so i'm
gonna go
thank you though for uh putting up with
me and enabling me
to do the things that i do which are
good things